the jurogan experience like i have a
tesla and i love my tesla i love it
today it's probably the best car that i
have
but there's something that i miss and
what i miss is the
i wanna i wanna feel
the gear i want to feel the i push the
left pedal down
the clutch engages i push the gear shift
into third gear
i let the clutch out i push down the gas
there's this interaction with this thing
that lets me
i'm i'm engaged i'm feeling it
there's something about those those kind
of old cars and
mechanical watches and there's a lot of
other things that
i those things excite me yeah tactile
it's like a dance yeah i like cooking
over
fire you know what i'm saying like
there's there's things that i still
like that are older things i like
running on dirt
you know there's i like those things
like chopping wood this thing there's
tactile
experiences you know yeah i i know those
are
dying i know they're dying the manual
gearbox is dying
my my car still a stick i talked about
last time i was like the mazda3
it's a stick shift people are kissing
with masks on do you understand what's
happening
yes yeah yeah yeah people are making out
two masks on
no one says they're dangerous dangerous
people
but you know i'm saying like that i feel
like mass kissing
is like it's a step in the wrong
direction
it's we're going to become aliens we're
going to become
the grays with the big black eyes the
giant heads
yeah we're not going to kiss at all
anymore no we're going to do it all
through our brains that'll be a relic of
the past
yeah it's going to be like the
difference between a tesla and a
manual 1970 chevelle is going to be the
difference between
real [ __ ] and and people just
plugging into some [ __ ] some computer
and
just letting it all happen inside some
virtual reality experience
where you don't have to worry about
cooties that's what i'm worried about
man
i'm worried about tactile human
experiences and i'm not really worried
i'm recognizing that the same way
if you wanted to if you wanted to look
back on
primates and your early primates and go
like if you brought a chimp
you know into the future and said hey
this is what it's gonna be like gonna
fly in plains and you're gonna
you're gonna eat off plates like [ __ ]
that i like swinging from trees and i
like throwing my own [ __ ] at my enemies
like i can't give that up yeah i'm not
giving up throwing
[ __ ] i like [ __ ] in my hand and giving
him a good time
yeah and i [ __ ] get together with my
other chimp buddies and we [ __ ] up some
dude who crossed our imaginary line we
kill them
you know there's there's parts of that
that for sure
life is better today but i'm not
a future human i'm a current human and
in in my current state there's tactile
experiences that i enjoy
i like kissing i like holding hands i
like
shaking a person's hand when i meet them
i like drinking whiskey
i like driving cars i like shifting my
own gears i like opening doors for
myself
whenever there's one of those things
where like you step towards it and the
door opens up
i never use those [ __ ] things i grab
that handle
i open that [ __ ] up i like opening
doors i like
i want to i want to experience things
yeah i want to i want to interact with
the world
i like interacting yeah i think there'll
always be a place for that
no no more well kovat has put a wrench
into that
covet is a it's basically showing us
what the future holds in store for us
what the future holds in store for us is
the elimination of biological threats
and there's a lot of biological threats
that we take
for granted like emotions hormones
the desire to breed conquering the
the natural primate instincts to
dominate
environments and to expand our
boundaries and our kingdoms
all those things are dangerous they're
not good but they also create art
and romance and controversy and they
they
they provide people within enthusiasm
and motivation there's all these things
about
being a human that creates art and makes
things
like wine they it makes things worth
living whiskey cigars
i do yes the kinetic nature of life
pre-covet
you know what i mean like bumping into
someone going to
something just serendipitously meeting
someone
yeah that doesn't happen anymore really
now everything is just so
it happens in texas i'm two days in so
i'm learning but
i'm gonna take you around yeah yeah
we're gonna be fine
yeah yeah the people that don't want it
to go back are the people that are most
fearful
the people that are like my grandmother
i understand
i get it yeah it's a terrifying tragedy
that anybody has to die from a disease
but we have to recognize that we're all
going to die
and you can't stop all life because a
disease comes along and kills some of us
we have to recognize what can we do to
mitigate the
dangers of this disease plus what can we
do
to mitigate the dangers of dissolving
our culture
we haven't done that instead we've only
concentrated on
mitigating the dangers of spreading
something so stay home
wear three masks touch no one wear
gloves while you're driving
like [ __ ] man this is not life this is
not life
and most of these people that are three
masked people they don't know god damn
anything about vitamins and quercetin
and
saunas and all the different methods you
can use to
stimulate your immune system it's like
we're we're
we don't want people to be able to take
their own
chances and make their own risks and the
more liberal you are
the more left-wing you are the more
likely you are
to appeal to authoritarianism and this
is one of the most
discouraging aspects of our culture in
2021
is that like these all these people that
are supposed to be like left-wing people
in my when i was a kid
i thought of i've always been left-wing
i've always been my
my family's like my my step-dad's a
hippie
he was a hippie my mom they were they
were very like open-minded
left-wing people there i it was all
about free expression
it was all about letting people be who
they are and and living whatever life
you wanted to be in
and accepting people for who they are
that's not what's happening now this is
all this
fear-based weird appeal to
authoritarianism to
there's too much disinformation on the
internet we have to have a
czar of truth there's people calling for
a czar of truth
do you know this no this is the new
thing they're asking for the government
to create a
czar of truth the [ __ ] government to
decide what's real and what's not
to just to dispel disinformation so you
can pull this up czar
of truth this is something that cnn has
talked about
a lot of these like [ __ ] weirdo
networks have talked about
like do you do you understand these
[ __ ] people understand what happens
when you start censoring people
we start saying things like we need the
government to step in the government's
never been good at anything
they've never been good at anything not
one [ __ ] thing
have they been grateful this whole like
crisis like businesses are suffering
they're just
if you're business you're [ __ ]
especially in l.a 75
of all early restaurants are gone yeah
there's no contingency plan in place
and then also they're like stay home but
then how do you make money
yeah so you can't have it both ways you
have to have like a safety net in place
the the people that are making these
distinctions and making these decisions
they don't lose a paycheck
that's the problem all these mayors and
governors and
health board advisors they don't miss a
[ __ ] paycheck they can shut down
everything
and they do it for optics well yeah
there i think there's a way to be smart
about this obviously this is a real
thing
and it does affect people but yeah but
listen man you got through it
i got through it yeah sure but like i'm
i'm younger and i know there are cases
where
where people are hit really hard by this
but i think
sometimes there's bureaucracy attached
to it where you're not even using
logic like the comedy story you know
they were they were all out before this
like
look it's in purple tier right now
whatever it is they've opened here
yeah yeah outdoor dining is allowed now
in los angeles
but when i made a decision to come out
here everything was clamped down
but before it was clamped down they did
have outdoor dining and all that
and the comedy store was allowed to have
outside seating in the parking lot you
know where we parked before we do our
sets
so there was tables there was chairs and
they could watch tv they could watch a
football game they could watch the
comedy store documentary they were able
to be
congregated in that parking lot but they
weren't allowed
to if you put a comedian doing jokes
outdoor
that was suddenly communism against the
rules
but like nothing has changed other than
instead of a tv
that their focus is on they are watching
a comedian
but for some reason the city deemed that
not allowable because the city is filled
the city government is filled with
people so [ __ ] stupid
they want to be a part of the city
government that's the problem
yes it's just me like on the ground in
your mouth all right thank you
it makes it makes no sense just to
anyone
it doesn't have to make sense and it was
frustrating because
before the shutdown when everything was
like super locked down
i was doing a lot of outdoor shows in la
and i was doing all these alt shows just
like in backyards and
on the top of hotels and stuff but the
comedy store wasn't allowed to do shows
because it was called the comedy store
there was too much attention on it
is that what it is yeah i think it's
just a bunch of fools
that's all it is it's just a bunch of
fools working in government
it doesn't have to make any sense they
just have to keep their jobs
and they have to give off they have to
give off the perception that they're
doing something
that that is helping and it's not true
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience